ねばい最近全然つい頼んでねーよみます音はなんだよね感応式信号かな
きてます今日撮って感応式信号あるのあると思います
こんにちははじめ社長です
[音楽]
久しぶりに文房具でもやりますっていうのも4月
学年が上がった方も卒業した人も入学した人も社会前始まった人もいろんな人がいると
思いますが皆さん
勉強の方いかがでしょう山路で最初の方はやり切れると思うんですよ新しい学校入っ
たりとか逆に上がったりしたときはちょっと勉強のやる気が出るんですけど3弾続に
4月の終わり頃にかけているトイレ聞けなくなってきてこのも五月病になってしまう
ケースがよくあると思うんですよ
五月病になる前にちょっとこの規模いた入れ替えて勉強できるようにあの
を6
って思った面白そうな文法後ちょっと5種類準備いたしました
僕は最近地味に書くことが多くなってきたんでちょっと文房具よくが上がってきたので
ちょっとこのタイミングで皆さんがちょっとでもやる気になるような的な文房具見つけ
てきたので紹介していこうと思いますすげーいい動画
ボスれるんですけどもうまずはこちらですペンケースなんですけどもうラベル税
あとも取りやすいさっきスタンドペン係数
パブねスタンドペンケースこれちょっとまあこれすごいんですよめちゃくちゃこれ
使えるんですよちらに僕今使ってる宣言したぽのペンケースです
刃が付いてますこれなんで使ってるのことも5年くらい使ってるんですよね
youtube はじめた頃から使ってるんで5年くらい多分使っていると思います
長い間ありがとう
中身は結構普通なんですけどこういう感じの普通の中身なんですけど例えばで普通に
ペンを入れます
まあもちろんこうすると普通にペンケースとしても使えるんですけどすごいで志す開け
ますここのくぼみがとっ
お気になったと思うんですけどもこれを床に叩きつけるとパワーなびっくり園スターズ
んですこれがなぜ便利だと思いました
good コってこの様々なペン撮る時に来て開けちゃん過去そこがするのがめんど
くさいんですけどペンスタンドだったらもうこの中でおけるんですけど上に校正ペンが
あったら夫キャップ cba になったらすぐこうやってチェンジできて子供使え
るっていう王座の速度
すごい方が魅力的だなと思いましたん
次はこちらです lcd ライティングタブレット
精いっぱいというペーパー神にーさよならって言ってます
どんどんこれぞ良さそうでしたまぁ簡単に言うと近未来型のノートだと思ってもらえれ
ばいいと思いますノートでもない7日目物をみたいな感じだった気がします
まあなんか厳しい学校だとこういう電子機器持つてくだけで怒られたりしそうだから
ちょっと
怖いんだよなおいこんな感じで日ちょっとやってみます後ろにペンがついてねっと
きてるきてるきてるこういう感じでなんか水が書けるわけでございますよ
杉中タッチダウンのまずで g 買取みたい
まってこれマジで凄いんだけどやばいなんか俺ちょっと舐められてました
フェンダーがちょっとかけに帰るかなと思ってたんですけどもこれ本当にノートにも
使いてる感覚と超れていました
えすごいマジで感動してるトメハネハライまで綺麗に写りますで真ん中は須藤リセット
されるんですけどこれちゃんと横にロックボタンあってロックをちゃんとすると真ん中
のボタンを押しても消えなくなるんだと思います
続いてこちらたいねぇサーフィンの性がやっぱりしなかったんですけどもうちょっと良
さげなのを見つけたのでありました
もうじいさんと push push ビュー車
でございます amazon で買ったんですけどもカラーバリエーションがけっこう
ありました
でこれ何がすごいかと言いますとちょっと上げてみますパン基本的なこの上をノック
する出し方とあとあのよくあるフルフル振って出す出し方と横にボタンが2つ付いてる
と思うんですけれども
ボタンを押すだけでさあシーンが出てきますいいですねめっちゃ茎やすい
結構ぺー先が鋭くなってるで月
ほど写真のた気になると思いますグラフとかスマッシュとあっちらへんですね
なんか無駄がない感じですごい書きやすいですあのこれ
いいですよシャーペンで書いてるといかに早く写真を出すコっても結構大事なポイント
だと思ってそういう時にあのいろんな都市語ると思いますなんかノックが基本なんです
けどロックする時ってこの帰って言ってノックに構えるまでだいたい0.5秒くらい
かかるんですよの0.5日はもったいない
その分振るう時だったらこうすぐって触れるしても腑に乗ってなれば所に迷惑かかるん
じゃねちょっと
腕の振りがちょっとウザいというかこうなんか周りから見ると
みたいにちょっと控えるかもしれないので書いててボタンを押すだけでセグ写真が出る
ので一番目皿ない最新の出し方なのではないかなと僕は思いました
それに人によって写真の出し方ってこう個性が出ると思うのであのボタンをどうもやる
人もいると思いますといったためにべパクリフリーでもいけるし
ロックで無印版兄に対応した素晴らしいシャーペンなとか思いました続いてこちらへ
エルヴィンブック
ちょっとぼ
もよくわからないです面白そうなので買っちゃったところがある大ベストセラー1位
ですねこのエルフィンノート鉄は繰り返し使用可能なノートですフォースで何か
ae に使えるノートらしいですねまあでも普通のノートなノート自体はめちゃくちゃ
カッコイイですねお洒落なノートです中にちょっといろいろ説明がありますて電子
レンジでチンすると中身がリセットされてもう
1回使えるらしいでもこれフリクションだからじゃないんですかフリクションだから
入ったら消える的な奴なんだと思うんだけど
でなんか凄いのが回転中身はデータ化できるらしいんです綺麗
大須5位一瞬で超見やすくデータ化されますたペラノートだってカメラで撮るとなんか
あないじゃないですかめちゃくちゃ綺麗に鮮明に映りました
スゴ何回も使います
dell ノートそして内容がデータ化されるのでなくなる心配もない
[音楽]
ん
ブーブー
おおこれがストレス解消するペルな水です
なにこれ普通に欠けるのかなうままそこそ書きやすいですねば両方ペン先が付いてて赤
と黒になってますこれセクシーなチェレペン作業を収納できるんですよ
ってああ
あれこれひょっとして
すげーだろにハンドスピナーだった大津ゲー
これだと授業中の顛末ができるんで八かでストレートの端になりますうわーすげー
こいつまず下や使わねーよああ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ
というわけであの文房具とかノートとかそういうのってすごいモチベにつながると思う
ので5月病に負けないように頑張ってください